what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel sarah
garvey it's me
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it we have just opened
memberships on the channel so if you
guys want to see exclusive behind the
scenes footage sign up for our
memberships and while you're at it go
subscribe to sarah's channel subscribe
to my channel sara garvey
i'm sure will be in the description so
today
we are reacting to what is a woman what
is a woman
this is a bit of a stir this one i
thought it was you
know
you said you changed your gender when
you were here last night this is this is
it well this is
i changed to you you changed me yeah now
we're here yeah i'm a man
as you can see
so um who do you know who this person is
this is apparently a a doctor who does
the change
the gender changes
oh
yeah so
she's
quite well versed in changing children
and adults into their
preferred gender should have such a
children
that's messed up okay
my name is michelle forcier
and i have a medical degree from
university of connecticut residency
university of utah pediatrics and i've
worked for a number of different planned
parenthoods for 20 years i do advanced
contraception and abortion really quick
smasher pass
i mean she's already worked for planned
parenthood so she's already like she's
already started off on the wrong floor
and for some reason i don't know why why
do these people always have like blue or
green hair i don't get it i don't
understand i think i could pull it off
no don't should i do it i would do it
don't do it i'm telling you i do not
know why
these crazy leftists have green or blue
hair it's always the crazy ones i like
don't understand it let's see how crazy
she is okay
you know maybe she's a nice old lady we
don't know action as well as gender
hormones and sort of looking at the
whole sort of schema of gender sex and
reproductive
justice so you've done a lot of work in
this field could you just start by
telling us sure
at what age can a child first
begin to
transition into another gender or
identify themselves as
a gender different from how they were
born yeah well i mean there's there's
research and data that show that
babies and infants
understand differences in gender
some children
figure out their gender
really early
and the reason why we are because the
fact that she tried to put in
babies and infants that's me this is
this is too sinister for me
i don't
like how would a baby know
she's saying there's research that says
that babies and infants know
you know what i always say i don't need
to see a study to know that's not true
right like like it's just like people
take studies so out of context i don't
even know what she's talking about but
it's just common sense
but common sense isn't common with these
people that's the thing no
no
it's not common like
anyway her hair we'll see okay question
how old's your son he's nine he's nine
do you this month do you if he if he
really wanted to change his gender what
would you do at what age at this age
yeah i would tell him i would
i would explain a lot of things to him
um
as to why it doesn't make any sense yeah
do you know what i mean um
at some point in time my son wanted to
be sonic the hedgehog
because he loved sonic right when he was
like five he was like dad i wanna be
sonic i wanna be sonic and i'm like
yeah and so he used to run like sonic
everywhere we went it was a thing
well should i turn my son into sonic the
hedgehog according to these people
no so as a father who is trying to guide
their child i will
guide him in the way i see fit do you
know what i mean i actually had a
conversation about this yesterday with
somebody and they were saying um
um
i hope your son is gay
because she's because we were talking
about like this and i was like why would
you hope my son is gay oh so you can be
less ignorant and i was like isn't it
funny that the left they wish death on
people they wish all kinds of things on
people and conservative people
like people who are just rolling with
common sense they don't do that no like
conservatives can have a debate and not
attack who you are
but the left like they immediately go
for your character i was doing public
interviews yesterday
oh my gosh and immediately they they go
for well why would you do this do you
hate women i'm like i am a woman
i allegedly i guess i don't know i could
be a man now i could be a man
the reason why we are saying oh that's
that's interesting or important is
because they're figuring out their
gender identity is not necessarily
congruent with their sex assigned at
birth when the when the doctor sees the
penis and says this is a male
has a sex of male that's a arbitrary
distinction
telling that family based on that little
penis
that your child is absolutely 100
percent male identified no matter what
else occurs in their life
the thing is right you have to give him
some props because he knows she's
talking [ __ ] yeah and he's just like
i've got to get a city done the lead
attorney talks about how if someone's
being crazy you have to like not let
your face change
because like you want to let them keep
going yeah yeah yes yeah and hang
themselves basically yeah
he can't hide it
that's not correct
so what does gender affirmation care
you're a big proponent of if we walk
through a child
is sitting down with you is questioning
yeah their gender what's the gender
affirmation process
affirmation means that as a pediatrician
as someone who says my job is to provide
the best medical care for you
is i need to listen really carefully and
how i put it in words for kids so that
they can understand it is tell me your
story
where have you been in terms of your
gender and your gender identity how
would you how would your son respond to
that tell me your story he'd probably
tell me a story
he'd just be like all right so yesterday
i was with my friends and we were
playing football or whatever tell me
your story that's a that that's like
that's a
that's a statement you ask an adult you
don't ask a child that question well
because they don't even know
like what are
i mean it's funny i haven't been around
like a ton of kids in a while because i
grew up but i grew up like around
because i have nine siblings you know so
there's always like a child in the house
and like the difference in your brain
between when you're 9 and 15 is like
crazy you're a completely different
person so how are they gonna have
someone make a decision at nine that
would have it would affect the rest of
their life um
and that's the thing you're allowed to
do something that can affect the rest of
your life at that age but you're not
allowed to smoke
not allowed to drink oh yeah
but you can change your whole gender
okay do you know what i was doing when i
was 10
going
i was obsessed with japan i wanted to be
japanese
you could have had um
you could have been trans-racial i could
i yeah i was wearing kimonos
at the mall
and just like for fun because i thought
jack japan was supposed to do that
language i i didn't learn the language
but i memorized no i memorized some um
some what do you call it there's a
a movie that had some japanese in it and
i just memorized like the lines in the
movie and me and my friends would say it
back and forth to each other at the mall
kids
kids that's what kids do you can say i
was cool
i'm sure you thought you were cool no i
am i'm like so cool i was in terms of
your gender and your gender identity
where are you right now
and more excitingly where would you like
to be in the future have you ever met a
four-year-old
who believes in santa claus
says to someone who believes that
a fat man is traveling through the sky
and a flying reindeer at lightning speed
coming down his chimney with presence
would you say that this is someone who
maybe has a tenuous grasp on reality
they have an appropriate four-year-old
handle in reality that's very real for
them agreed agreed but santa claus is
real for them but yeah santa claus is
not actually real
and but santa claus does deliver their
christmas presents
see
see
see
to that child
they are so what she's saying is
you can create your own reality in your
head and if you believe it
it's true
that's why you can't argue with these
people but that's why people have like
schizophrenia and stuff like that they
create a world in their head and they
believe that they are going through all
of these things and this is why they get
medicated
because doctors know that that's
actually not reality what these people
are doing is saying okay the reality
that you've created in your head
yeah we'll make that your reality it's
crazy
it's actually insane and
oh my gosh because i don't know how you
could be this old like this is an old
lady and still believe this like i'm 25.
you know what i mean i'm like manosphere
gold you know she's got a primate 25 and
childless i'm almost going to hit my
wall someone's going to
snap you up soon you would think right
but but but no and i feel like at 25
i have a better grasp on reality than
this old lady yeah how should it be
unfortunately this shouldn't be
well yeah but it's not real though
to that child they are
when i see a child who you know believes
in santa claus and then let's say this
is a boy and he says i'm a girl
this is someone who can't distinguish
between fantasy and reality so
how could you take that
as a reality
i would say that as a pediatrician and
as a wait she's wait wait she's a
pediatric oh my god i forgot she was a
doctor
i totally forgot in this interview she
was a doctor because
she seemed so dumb she has to be
somewhat but she just constricted
herself because she said i would say how
wonderful my child's imagination is
so she's actually acknowledging
it's in here
i don't even catch that
because your imagination isn't it
so she's just acknowledged that it's in
the head
but i'm sure she'll still try and
justify i would say how wonderful my
four-year-old and their imagination is
male gametes that's what makes me male
no your your sperm don't make you male
then what does
it's a constellation in reality
in truth okay whose truth are we talking
about the same truth that says we're
sitting in this room right now you and i
no
you're not listening if i if i see a
chicken laying eggs and i say that's a
female chicken laying eggs did i assign
female or am i just observing a physical
reality that's happening in the world
does a chicken have gender identity does
a chicken cry okay but but these are the
same people that are gonna say like men
should cry the same as women and that
there's there's no difference between
male and female like the way we dress
like i said the other day
the whole thing is confusing because
like i was saying lesbians are women on
women
i can be a woman that means i can be a
lesbian that means you can be a gay man
maybe i am there you go you could be a
gay man the whole thing is just crazy
it's not making any sense or they'll say
like men can wear dresses
no like that the outfits don't make it
which basically is saying that dresses
aren't meant for men
they're meant for women but then they
can't art they can't answer what is a
woman
it's it's too it's too confusing though
it's too confusing
i forget people like this exist
sometimes because people around me are
pretty sane right so sometimes i forget
i would love to have her on my show i
would i would love a conversation with
her as well yeah she can commit suicide
let's reframe it because you're talking
you're trying chicken has sex like any
biological organisms an assigned gender
but a chicken doesn't have a gender
identity so we assign female to chickens
when they lay eggs that's it we assume
they're female if they lay eggs at what
age does the medical transition begin
with uh medication so medical
affirmation begins when the patient says
they're ready for it
so that could be
a kiddo who is just starting puberty
and panicking because they're getting
breast buds or their penis is getting
bigger and busier and they're worried
about all kinds of masculine changes and
that way puberty blockers which are
completely reversible
and
don't have permanent effects are
wonderful because we can put that pause
on puberty just like if you were
listening to music you put the pause on
and we stopped the blockers and puberty
would go right
back to where it was the next note in
the song
just what's that please spell they're
messing with your whole biology biology
this is what's so sinister about it for
me is that human beings have a biology
and the fact that they're going to stop
a natural process within every human
being
says that there's something wrong well
and she can't not know that there's
gonna be effects
like there has to be side effects from
that i'm not a doctor i don't have a
biology degree but it's just common
sense if you delay puberty there's gonna
be side effects from that that'll
probably last them the rest of their
lives
we said earlier on how can a child at
the age when they start to like when
they start puberty how can they know
that this is a decision that they want
until they're in their 60s no they don't
there are decisions that i made in my
20s i'm like what a stupid decision yeah
what do you know what i mean it's child
abuse i think
i think it is i think it's yeah i think
any parent that allows that is literally
i would say child abuse 18 you can do
what you want
but you're going to do that at 13 14 9
10. i was i thought i was japanese at
13. i said my son was sonic the hedgehog
what the hell
it's delayed that period of time one of
the drugs used as lupron right which
has actually been used to
chemically castrate sex offenders
you know what
i'm not sure that we should continue
with this interview because it seems
like it's going in a particular
direction well you're a medical
professional i am a medical professional
so you don't want to talk about the
drugs that you give to kids or
again
i'm a physician and i use medication
you're choosing exploitive words
drugs
i'm choosing a chemical word that was in
a dictionary that's not a correct term
for puberty blocking i could like look
it up on my phone but i'm pretty sure if
i looked it up
you can look it up on your phone it says
medical definition the administration of
a drug to bring about a mark reduction
in the body's production of androgens
and especially testosterone and i'm
saying as a pediatrician who takes care
of hundreds of these kids when you use
that terminology
she's saying that if you use the actual
definition you're being malignant and
harmful no they're trying to change
definitions
the audacity of these people you think
you have you have the power to change a
word
it's the victimhood though yeah yeah
it's like i'm gonna have a normal
conversation with you and as soon as you
ask me a tough question i'm gonna play a
victim oh my god like that's really bad
oh sorry that's really bad oh no i
agreed to this interview and he's asking
tough question like what the [ __ ] what
did you think what did you expect what's
gonna happen
this is what we do
we get paid to argue what are you people
people people like this is the way the
world is going i'm so glad that we have
an outlet to actually just like what if
what is it what if we had to just sit at
home and not tell the world
and not say anything and just watch it
just crumble as we're just sitting at
home no way no way all right
yeah thank god for youtube thanks for
listening guys i love complaining about
these people on camera
say that giving
chemical castration drugs to kids is
malignant and harmful it's about the
context of caring for a child and and
seeing the
the suffering that kids can have that
have not been in affirmative home
situations
so we're going on this journey
boys can be girls girls can be boys men
can be women women can be men
it makes me wonder
[Music]
what is a woman
what is a woman a woman is someone who
claims that as their identity
i'm a woman
i claim female and woman as my identity
as you can see i am i'm a man
i'm a fine ass man i'm a fine arts woman
apparently you know what i mean humble
yourself
is it possible i can be a specific woman
so can i be rihanna
i bet you could i mean that can i be
posting [ __ ]
who could i be
you could be
oh i could be will smith i'll leave
jayden
i'll do it for you i'll be jailer and
try to keep you okay where you going boy
but it's like these people are crazy i
don't under
and it's just crazy because i don't
think that we should be like
we shouldn't have to say this stuff no a
common sense should be common but like i
said common sense is definitely not
common amongst these people no it's not
no and um like we've already said like
oh you know facts don't care about your
feelings but clearly we're living in a
world now where
feelings trump facts do you think she's
married
if she is she's probably married to a
woman
whatever she is married to i feel like
this is what happens when women are
single too long
i feel like this is what happens when
feminism takes over the world yeah that
too
but what are feminists they'd be lonely
come on
and then they and then they start to
live in their heads
they start to create
could be many things to many people
that was our answer well a woman is
anyone and that was by the way not to
give any spoilers away but
that is
the answer
from the left to the question which is a
non-answer it's the same thing as not
answering at all but that is that is the
answer the woman is someone who says
their will
and of course do everyone who gives me
that answer in the film i have the
follow-up well a woman is someone who
identifies as a woman what are they
identifying as and around and around we
go
because they don't have an answer to the
question this is a
medical doctor
um
who can't tell you what a woman is
i mean this is someone who who
if someone goes to her and says as a man
and says you know i'm really a woman i
want to transition into a woman
she will help facilitate that process
and yet she doesn't know what the word
means
she doesn't actually know she by her own
testimony
when someone says i want to transition
to a woman she doesn't even know what
that means like what are you
transitioning into
she has no idea
wow wow wow wow
oh my gosh i can't believe people like
that example
doctor
a doctor i need to see the film was when
you were in because you're an actor yeah
when you were
acting like full-time or whatever
did were there a lot of crazies in
acting
there are a lot of flamboyant
a lot we call them la dee da people you
know
what i mean and so
yeah like i wouldn't say crazy i would
say like
creative oh okay and sometimes that
creativeness could go into a place yeah
which is why they take so much [ __ ]
drugs as well like oh do they oh my god
i'm telling you the first time i started
acting right remember i'm i'm coming
from
before the age of
i got into acting when i was in my teens
okay
i
had never i'd been around people i've
sold drugs i've been around people that
had smoked weed okay
i had never smoked or drunk in my life
until i hit the age of like 27. oh
really wow yeah so i went to
into this world
i was told tea tall within a drink and
smoke yeah yeah and when i got into that
world
the way people took cocaine mm-hmm
oh what coke coke
they would
see a water yeah offer it to you like
glass water oh really i hate you you
want to join
oh wow how about i
no i'm good
i've only found that with finance people
like my friends from college that went
into finance
they would always be the ones at the
party doing coach
and then us normal people were just like
oh i'm good yeah it's like
i've never seen it before i'm not like i
was it was kind of like a shock to me
and then some of the people that i got
quite close with in the acting world
were like
you know probably onto it i can't be
around
i was just wondering because i it seems
like the creatives seem to have more
like left in them
but that's why i i don't see a lot of
super left people in medicine
because usually it's
usually rooted in reality yeah yeah yeah
that's right so how did this woman make
it through medical school like how did
she answer her exams
it's my question when that's a good
question yeah like how to be a
pediatrician
you have to
treat children so there are boys and
girls
so how did she get past maybe she
started it
and then changed her mind to um at some
point yeah maybe because she it's she's
old
oh my gosh that was
literally nuts
um well any final thoughts about the
video
um
um i just think that people in general
need to start living in reality
i think you know
i know it sounds it sounds really easy
you know yeah yeah it sounds really easy
but for some people it's just not easy
enough like it's hard i don't know
no i agree like i think
and i think that it's also around the
people around them for letting them live
in illusion that's why that's why you're
great on the show
you don't you don't let these hoes no i
don't i don't let
i speak my mind and i'm quite firmly
yeah you know what i mean
it rubs people the wrong way but
yeah i can't change yeah yeah so my dm's
are still cold
i'm just saying
um okay guys um don't forget to like
this video and let us know in the
comments what we should react to next
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell subscribe
to sarah garvey's channel please um all
the links will be in the description
we'll talk to you guys next time bye